this dress it's like the SATs hey guys
it's Eric Nam and I'm here at tasty and
we're gonna make my favorite eggs and
even more Chinese I'm not gonna eat them
Inc is gonna eat them so excited I'm
just gonna try not to kill you here we
go it's very very simple guys we're
gonna take a bowl we got some eggs we're
gonna do three eggs I have three eggs in
a bowl trying to process what I do raise
chopsticks because chopsticks are really
great for cooking they're nimble and
they aren't like this two little sticks
now we're gonna put a little milk in it
too it's kind of oh there you go your
milks gonna make a little bit more
fluffy and a little creamier we're gonna
start whisking if you want to get
technical go to culinary school follow a
recipe on tasty this is not one that you
should follow you could follow it but
I'm just all right right definitely put
a little too much milk in it this is how
eggs are supposed to look right you know
what because there is a whisk I'm just
gonna try it and you know what I'm gonna
do I'm gonna add another egg you look
hungry too look this is clunky
chopsticks so much better it's a little
more edgy there we go there's the
egginess
now I do I asked for truffles do you
think it's bougie exactly why it's for
truffles what I actually have travels in
my house hell no these are going to be
gone and like dead and rotted and Suzhou
shaved truffles carpaccio and extra
virgin olive oil they are from Italy oh
it smells so good you can cook your eggs
in olive oil I'm actually gonna do them
with butter because I've never done it
with butter before I'm gonna go low heat
long time fluff them up just fluff up
your eggs just gonna go back to the
chopsticks shot at the chop whoever made
chopsticks couple hundred or thousand
years I don't know brilliant
there we go you have it on that's why it
wasn't heating up I'm looking at the
truffles and I really don't know what
I'm gonna do with them I'm just gonna
get really inventive that's enough about
it right drop it in here we're gonna
take some truffles I've never used
truffles before just gonna chop them up
just a little bit do I look like a chef
it's David Chang gonna call me be like
yo you have some really good knifing
skills you want to join my team like how
much you gonna pay bro
oh wow these are definitely warmed up
when I throw the truffles in here
because we're gonna get that truffle
flavor into the butter instead of having
big chunks of truffles in your eggs
I think truffles are best when there's
like a hint of truffle nice too much
truffles and you're like wow that's like
so overwhelming I have like fungus all
over my food I'm gonna add the eggs I'm
like really stressed right now because I
need this to work out add these in now
it's a question of how are we gonna cook
these I actually don't know but I'm
gonna use chopsticks right now is that
enough it's probably enough we're gonna
put a little salt in it a little
seasoning coarsely ground black pepper
how do you like your eggs you're eating
it you should tell me okay all right
we're going scrambled that's what's
happening we're gonna scramble them up
just like this and we're done
but these look horrible so okay
look it smells like nothing meaning it's
definitely under flavored underseasoned
I like you barely smell the truffle like
you smelled butter we're gonna do a
little bit of garnish right here
horribly cut can't even do these all
right here's what we're gonna do we have
this version of eggs right here those
are there but I'm insecure and I have
more eggs left so we're gonna do one
more version see how this turns out
welcome to tasty y'all we're gonna get
some butter on this skillet I'm gonna
get more truffles distressed just like
the SATs I swear to god they're amazing
oh you hear that crackling sound of oh
did you see that jumpin truffle it just
just jumped up god I hope this is good
we're gonna use a new technique to
finish off these eggs guys
your fault I'm not eating these I don't
know I like I'm actually don't know what
I'm doing here's my thing with eggs just
eat them anything's fine I'm trying to
make you a nice omelet it's not working
maybe I'll turn the heat up just a
little bit
why is this not cooking I try this get
the edges we're gonna try rolling them
that's what we're gonna do
do you think it's gonna work you don't
look confident in my abilities it's fine
we should definitely do the chef's flip
- one - whoo I knew that was gonna work
out works out perfectly I might have
pulled something my neck now we're going
to tuck this in somehow
you know what it's probably done and
it's probably perfect so I'm gonna go
ahead and plate this for you that's
supposed to break off look I'm just
gonna top it off with some salt you know
it's a little bit of seasoning all right
we'll give it a little bit of chili
flakes perfect fluffy beauty miss
perfectly done truffled eggs I just hope
you like these eggs and if you don't I'm
just gonna say like maybe like your
flavor profile is it yeah you might want
a lot of sriracha sauce - mm-hmm all
right thank you
her face is getting red I'm really
nervous right now it's really good that
was a very very again a very mousy very
good it was very good okay
he's right really mmm I know you added
salt later it was a really nice touch
and then I like the chives in there and
then the truffle you were right about
the truffles it's like just enough so
you get a hint a bit of it and it's not
just like I'm bougie I'm gonna add you
let me say it's like we're a budget
bougie right yeah you don't try you
should try it I should try it because I
have no idea what this tastes like
very good no I should have my own series
this is great tasty I like I'm open to
doing whatever you want with good all
right guys thanks so much for watching I
hope you guys try these eggs they're
very very good don't be surprised when
they're so good you freak out and pass
out cuz they're freaking amazing thanks
for having me if you guys make it go
ahead and tag me on the social so I can
see if you make them better than me you
probably can but in the mean time as you
make your actors you listen to my new
album it's called before we begin and
the lead single is congratulations and
it's a jam so I hope you enjoy it and
I'll see you guys soon
[Music]